john gruden who i'm reliably informed as
the head coach or was the head coach of
the las vegas raiders i'm i'm about as
much of a
raiders fan as i am a fan of
the superman comic books but john gruden
was the head coach and he just resigned
he resigned under pressure he had to
resign because
decade old or even more than a decade
old emails
personal emails were leaked and in those
emails he sometimes said politically
incorrect things
notably calling the commissioner of at
the nfl
a i'll clean up the language a little
bit a wuss
a clueless wuss which every single
person knows that he is even i know that
i don't follow football at all and even
i know that roger goodell is a clueless
wuss okay and so this football coach
puts that in his emails private emails
they are leaked a decade or more later
now he has to resign and he said other
things and he made
insensitive comments and now he's got to
got to resign
what this
is i think
is bigger than just
cancel culture or saying that people
should have their their private emails
protected you know i think the angle
that most conservatives are focusing on
with the john gruden story is that
liberal democracy requires there to be a
distinction between the public and the
private sphere and then in the 1970s the
second wave feminists came in and said
the personal is political and all your
private stuff is actually public now and
we're going to scrutinize all of it and
we're going to hold you to account for
things you say at home or who does the
dishes or or what have you
there's an aspect of that sure but this
goes a little bit further and and well
people are focusing on this comment in
one of the emails where he commented on
a black player's large lips and they're
saying that he's basically you know
david duke because he he made some
racially insensitive comment i think the
more telling comments are about
sexuality and masculinity where he calls
goodell a big wuss
what we're seeing here is a cultural
revolution one that is aimed
specifically
at anti-masculinity
and we're seeing this paired up with a
technological
revolution which is namely the
surveillance revolution
so to bring that back down to earth what
we're seeing is standards changing
completely on sexuality and so
beyond
you know your sexual desires or your
sexual partners it's even it's even down
to what a man is or what a woman is it's
even down to this idea now that
masculinity is toxic in the old standard
masculinity was good the word virtue
itself is related to the word for man
right and so there was something good at
john wayne gary cooper i i'm reminded of
tony soprano a line that would come
we've been talking about tony soprano
recently because it was columbus day and
one one of the lines from that show that
keeps coming up is what have happened to
men like gary cooper what do you know
whatever happened to john wayne whatever
happened to the straw father knows best
the strong man now when we look at at
male figures in the culture they're all
a bunch of bumbling idiots right it's
homer simpson or ray romano and they
can't do anything and they're they're
just a big joke and their their wife has
to do everything and take care of them
because these guys can barely put their
their pants on in the morning so there's
an attack on masculinity and a lot of
what's in these emails these john gruden
emails
is locker room talk i know it's a an
overused expression these days and it's
expression that that really
hit the mainstream when donald trump was
caught on a secret tape also let's not
forget on a hot mic on a secret tape
that had been held for years and years
saying that when you're a celebrity
women let you do whatever you want you
can grab them by the you-know-what
you can grab them by the roger goodell
and
at the time
a bunch of pearl clutches said oh my
gosh donald trump is openly advocating
for rape first of all he's not talking
about sexual assault at all he said they
let you do it so even even within the
context of his joke he wasn't joking
about that but second of all he wasn't
being serious he was joking around he
was having a little locker room talk a
little rough talk which is the way that
men
sometimes speak and when i say sometimes
i mean all men at some point have talked
like this and it it doesn't mean
anything it doesn't mean that you're
hateful doesn't mean that you're bigoted
it doesn't mean that if john gruden is
calling
what's his name roger goodell a clueless
wuss doesn't mean that he
harbors a deep-seated hatred of
homosexuals or if he makes fun of some
guy's lips it doesn't mean he hates
black people it does it just means he's
talking a little bit rough and a little
offensively and a little aggressively
which is something that we used to
expect from football players and
football coaches
all right these these are people
football players who
who get involved in dog fighting rings
remember that these are people who get
involved in really tough they're
disproportionately likely to commit
crimes you can be arrested i mean there
are actually some really bad crimes that
football players have committed in
recent years but some of them have
beaten their wives and girlfriends some
of them have committed murder but the
one that we're all supposed to lose our
our collective sense over is because
this guy used some harsh language
in emails
why do we even know about the harsh
language because of the technological
aspect the surveillance state why do we
know about donald trump's joke to billy
bush on the access hollywood show
because of the surveillance state
it's become more and more and more so
anything you've ever said
in your email in your texts in your
private messages any certainly anything
you've ever tweeted
anything you've ever searched for
basically anything you've ever thought
anything you've ever said you know how
you talk and then all of a sudden you're
getting ads on your cell phone for
things that you were just talking about
in a normal conversation to someone in
real life
these things are all
pairing up and because
the people who have control because the
ruling class are the ones pushing for
this cultural revolution the asymmetries
of power here are very very concerning
because people who
descend from the political orthodoxy of
the culture are increasingly going to
have their private emails leaked and the
private conversations leaked and the
worst things they've ever said and done
are going to be broadcast and used to
ruin their lives and then people who go
along with the leftist orthodoxy are
going to have even the worst crimes that
they can commit excused i'm so glad you
liked that clip if you don't mind
leave me a comment say you like the clip
that's very sweet of you
and uh subscribe and ring the bell and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael noel
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]